We now revisit the exponential
random variable that we
introduced earlier and develop
some intuition about what it
represents.
We do this by establishing a
memorylessness property,
similar to the one that we
established earlier in the
discrete case for the
geometric PMF.
Suppose that it is known that
light bulbs have a lifetime
until they burn out,
which is an
exponential random variable.
You go to a store, and you are
given two choices, to buy a
new light bulb, or to buy a used
light bulb that has been
working for some time and
has not yet burned out.
Which one should you take?
We want to approach this
question mathematically.
So let us denote by capital T
the lifetime of the bulb.
So time starts at time 0, and
then at some random time that
we denote by capital T, the
light bulb will burn out.
And we assume that this random
variable is exponential with
some given parameter lambda.
In one of our earlier
calculations, we have shown
that the probability that
capital T is larger than some
value little x falls
exponentially
with that value x.
We are now told that a certain
light bulb has already been
operating for t time units
without failing.
So we know that the value of the
random variable capital T
is larger than little t.
We are interested in how much
longer the light bulb will be
operating, and so we look at
capital X, which is the
remaining lifetime from the
current time until the light
bulb burns out.
So capital X is this particular
random variable
here, and it is equal to capital
T minus little t.
Let us now calculate the
probability that the light
bulb lasts for another
little x time units.
That is, that this random
variable, capital X, is at
least as large as
some little x.
That is, that the light
bulb remains alive
until time t plus x.
We use the definition of
conditional probabilities to
write this expression as the
probability that capital X is
bigger than little x.
On the other hand, capital
X is T minus t, so we
write it this way--
T minus t is bigger than little
x, and also that T is
bigger than little t, divided
by the probability of the
conditioning event.
Just write this event in a
cleaner form, capital T being
larger than little t plus x and
being larger than little
t, again divided by the
probability of the
conditioning event.
And now notice that capital T
will be greater than little t
and also greater than little t
plus x, that is, capital T is
larger than this number and this
number, if and only if it
is larger than this second
number here.
So in other words, the
intersection of these two
events is just this event here,
that capital T is larger
than little t plus x.
Now, we can use the formula
for the probability that
capital T is larger
than something.
We apply this formula, except
that instead of little x, we
have t plus x.
And so here we have e to the
minus lambda t plus x divided
by the probability that capital
T is bigger than t.
So we use this formula, but with
little t in the place of
little x, and we obtain e
to the minus lambda t.
We have a cancellation, and
we're left with e to the minus
lambda x, which is a final
answer in this calculation.
What do we observe here?
The probability that the used
light bulb will live for
another x time units is exactly
the same as the
corresponding probability that
the new light bulb will be
alive for another
x time units.
So new and used light bulbs
are described by the same
probabilities, and they're
probabilistically
identical, the same.
Differently said, the used light
bulb does not remember,
and it is not affected by how
long it has been running.
And this is the memorylessness
property of
exponential random variables.
Let us now build some additional
insights on
exponential random variables.
We have a formula for the
density, the PDF.
And from this, we can calculate
the probability that
T lies in a small interval.
For example, for a small delta,
this probability here
is going to be approximately
equal to the density of T
evaluated at 0 times delta,
which is lambda times e to the
0, which is 1, times delta.
What if we are told that the
light bulb has been alive for
t time units?
What is the probability that it
burns out during the next
delta times units?
Since a used but still
alive light bulb is
probabilistically identical to
a new one, this conditional
probability is the same as this
probability here that a
new light bulb burns out in the
next delta times units.
And so this is also
approximately
equal to lambda delta.
So we see that independently of
how long a light bulb has
been alive, during the next
delta time units it will have
a lambda delta probability
of failing.
One way of thinking about this
situation is that the time
interval is split into little
intervals of length delta.
And as long as the light bulb
is alive, if it is alive at
this point, it will have
probability lambda delta of
burning out during the next
interval of length delta.
This is like flipping a coin.
Once every delta time steps,
there is a probability lambda
delta that there is a success
in that coin flip, where
success corresponds to having
the light bulb actually burn
down, and the exponential random
variable corresponds to
the total time elapsed until
the first success.
In this sense, the exponential
random variable is a close
analog of the geometric random
variable, which was the time
until the first success in
a discrete time setting.
This analogy turns out to be
the foundation behind the
Poisson process that
we will be studying
later in this course.